[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a mystery thriller film called
king's game spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
the story surrounds a class of 32 school
students studying at tamaoka high one
night the protagonist of the film chimi
gets a message from a strange number the
message says that her class has been
chosen to play the world's most unique
game called the king's game the rules
are simple one no one is allowed to
withdraw from playing and two the king's
order has to be completed within 24
hours at the end of the text the king
gives them their first task the student
in the 28th rank has to confess his
feelings to his crush chimi ignores the
strange message and gets a good night's
sleep the next day she walks to school
with her childhood best friend nobuoaki
it turns out that he also received the
same text they laugh at it believing it
to be some kind of prank soon the class
discovers that the message was sent to
all of them by the same number they
urged the 28th kid to reveal who his
crush is on popular demand he walks up
to the girl and confesses his feelings
although the girl rejects him the class
gets a good laugh out of it anyone else
having flashbacks to high school
suddenly all of their phones ring at the
same time they receive a text from the
king that says the mission has been
completed later that night the king
texts them the second task according to
which number 4 and 19 have to kiss each
other the king is starting to seem like
a pervert in the classroom some people
think the prank has gone too far but
number 19 has no problem kissing number
four she walks up to him and plants a
brief kiss just for the classes
entertainment the guy is left flustered
as everyone erupts into cheers some of
the girls do not like the fact that
their classmates are supporting the
pranks but until they know who is behind
it they cannot take any action that
night they again receive a text with a
third task this time the guy with rank
18 is told to touch number three number
three is horrified to read the message
because she doesn't want to be the
center of attention in the classroom the
following morning the guys are excited
hoping to see something out of the
ordinary however their excitement
vanishes when they find out number three
didn't come to school later that night
all students get a text saying that
since number three and 18 didn't obey
the king's order their existence will be
erased right then their pictures from
the class photo disappear seconds later
they receive yet another text for the
next task number 20 and 17 will have to
have sex this is even more complicated
because number 17 misaki has a
short-tempered boyfriend named yahiro
who won't even allow her to talk to
other guys the class doesn't think much
of it until the following day when they
noticed the students who didn't complete
their task yesterday are absent moreover
their seats are missing and their phone
numbers have been erased from everyone's
cell phones when the teacher enters the
classroom they tell her about the
missing students to their utter surprise
the teacher says that no students of
such names have ever been in the class
the students finally realized that king
was serious about erasing their
existence after the class they check the
school's record book but cannot find the
missing students names as a last resort
they call the students parents and
discover that they have completely
forgotten about their own children's
existence the only people who know
number three and 18 once existed are the
students in the class the most nervous
of them all is misaki who has been
tasked to sleep with number 20. her
boyfriend yahiro threatens number 20 to
stay away from his girlfriend no matter
what he still doesn't want to believe
that the game is real but misaki has
made up her mind that night chimi stays
at her best friend nobuoaki's house
because her father is not in town they
have dinner together with nobuwaki's
parents and little sister after dinner
chimi and nobuwaki are in his room when
they get a text saying that the last
task has been completed meaning that the
two students must have slept with each
other for their next mission everyone
will have to follow yahiro's orders for
an entire day the task stirs trouble
because yahiro is especially mad at
number 20 for sleeping with his
girlfriend the next day he slaps misaki
for cheating on him and is even more
furious when number 20 doesn't come to
school he orders number 20 to die at
that very instant because his orders
must be followed somewhere else number
20 suffers from heart failure and dies
in the middle of the road passers-by
stop to check up on him but suddenly
they ignore his existence and go about
their day seconds later his dead body
disappears along with all his belongings
in the classroom the students are left
stunned to see his desk vanish they
discuss what might be causing this but
get no definite answers some students
want to inform the police but they
acknowledge that no one would believe
the absurd story
after school a girl named ria calls
chimi nobuoaki and his friend nyoya to
the library for some reason ria seems to
know a lot more about king than anyone
else she claims that the king is a curse
to their class when asked how she knows
this she doesn't give them a straight
answer and walks away that night they
get the sixth task in which two students
number 22 and six have to take part in a
popularity contest all the students must
vote for either one of them and the one
with the least votes will be punished
anyone who refuses to vote will also be
punished the following day at class
number 22 and six are nervous nobuoaki
takes a stand and asks half the students
to vote for 22 and the other half for
six that way they can manipulate the
votes and save both of them without
breaking any rules everyone does is told
but when it is time to count the votes
someone seems to have not obeyed the
rules number 22 gets an additional vote
and is saved meanwhile number six freaks
out thinking that she is about to
disappear in the moment of panic she
dies this means that king didn't get to
punish her for losing seconds later her
dead body disappears the students get
another text saying that since king
didn't get to punish her for losing in
her place number 26 will die until she
confesses her sin the class realizes
that number 26 voted for the guy to kill
number six just because she didn't like
her everyone knows the truth but 26
doesn't confess her sin and runs away
because of this she also disappears
everyone blames nobuoaki for causing two
deaths instead of one because of his
stupid idea later that day rhea calls
chimi to the library and shows her
several news articles that report
similar incidents together they discover
that over the years the entire class of
students has gone missing on several
occasions but if they cease to exist
completely who remembered their
disappearance and made the articles the
articles also contained the class
pictures of the missing students in each
of the pictures there is a guy who looks
an awful lot like nobuoaki this makes
ria believe he might be related to the
disappearances however chimi doesn't
believe her since she has known nobuaki
since her childhood the only reason ria
can come up with is that king might have
manipulated chimi into thinking she
knows nobuoaki later that day they get
the next task from the king this time
the students have to put all their pens
inside a single box then they have to
take out the pens one after another
according to their numbers one person
can only take three or fewer pens at a
time the individual who has to take the
last pen will lose and hence disappear
the class does as told and a guy ends up
with the last three pens if he takes one
nobuoki will die and if he takes two now
you will initially the guy belittles
nobuwaki for killing number six who he
loved for a long time in the end he
takes all three pens sacrificing himself
because he feels guilty for not being
able to save number six yesterday
that day while returning home chimi and
the group find two girls laughing and
chatting like everything is great on
being asked they say that they have
found a brilliant idea to stop king from
ever troubling them again later that day
chimi and nobuaki go to chimi's house
because her father is not home nobuaki
notices pictures on the wall but finds
it weird that none of them have people's
faces it is also interesting that since
the beginning of the movie chimi's
father has either been talking to her
from his room or has been out of town as
chimi and nobuwaki are talking they
receive a text from king saying that
someone has been disqualified for
breaking the rules soon several of such
messages start popping up on their
screen now he calls them and reveals the
brilliant idea that the girls were
talking about earlier was to simply
block the king however they didn't take
into consideration the rule that said
anyone who withdraws from the game will
be removed because of the mistake most
of the students vanish leaving only
eight of them alive for the next task
the class president is asked to text the
word die to two people of their choice
the ones who receive the text won't be
killed the next day the teacher comes to
the class and doesn't notice that most
of them have disappeared a frustrated
class president asks her to look around
and breaks down crying chimi takes her
to the washroom to calm her down but
when the president is in a bathroom
stall alone she dies when chimi comes
looking for her she finds a puddle of
blood but the president has already
disappeared soon they receive a text
from king informing them of the class
president's decision since she couldn't
complete the task the responsibility
falls upon nobuoaki whoever he sends the
text to will die but he has to text
three people instead of just two by now
the students know that in the end all of
them are going to die but they do not
want to go down without a fight chimi
nawya and ria stay in the school while
nobuwaki and the three others go for a
trip to the oldest school where the
disappearance first took place according
to the articles since it was a long time
ago the students didn't have telephones
king used to communicate with them
through letters the game was played in
the same way and there seemed to be a
winner in the end the students separate
to the different parts of the school
looking for any useful evidence of the
game's origin but all of a sudden
someone hits nobuoaki on his head and
knocks him out when he wakes up he sees
that three of his classmates have tied
him up it turns out that they have also
seen the pictures from the article and
discovered that nobuoaki is in all of
them this led them to believe he is in
fact the king and if they kill him they
won't have to play the games anymore
somewhere else rhea who has analyzed the
game thoroughly claims that the articles
are a trap if no one can remember the
past of the disappeared students the
articles shouldn't exist this means that
it is one of the king's tricks to make
the students go against each other when
the group puts two and two together they
realize that the other three who are
with nobuoaki have fallen into king's
trap and are probably trying to kill him
nauya immediately calls nobuwaki but the
group declines he is now sure that his
friend is in trouble somewhere else the
three students are seconds away from
killing nobuoaki but to his fortune they
disappear right before they cause him
any harm it turns out that now he logged
into nobuwaki's email and sent them all
a text saying die this completed king's
task and made them disappear right after
the surviving students receive another
text that says naoya will be eliminated
because he pretended to be someone he
wasn't a distressed nobuwaki quickly
calls his friend who disappears while
talking to him after that nobuwaki
searches the school and finds a picture
that he once saw in chimi's house
back in the school ria has finally
debunked what the main aim of the king's
game is she thinks that the operator of
the game is not king in fact the game is
made to make the king suffer throughout
the game everything has been fair except
when the operator played a foul card and
made the students falsely believe
nobuaki is the king his intention was
clear he wanted nobuoaki to die and with
nobuwaki's death the person who hurts
the most would be chimi this means that
the game was made to hurt and trouble
chimi which makes her the king chimi
refuses to believe her and runs to the
classroom there nobuwaki is waiting for
her in his seat he reveals that when the
king's game was first played there was
one winner the said winner was chimi
herself nobuoaki has also discovered
that when she won the game she refused
to be the next king like she was
supposed to so as a curse she was made
immortal and her memories were erased
ever since she has joined many new
schools with a new memory of her
childhood and new friends and every
single time she has had to watch them
die and suffer her initial trauma again
and again nobuaki thinks the only way to
stop her from creating more king's games
is by killing her at the same time ria
receives a text saying that she is a
threat to the continuation of the king's
game hence she will have to die in the
end only nobuwaki and chimi are left he
launches at her to kill her but she
manages to run downstairs in the
following struggle chimi kills nobuoaki
to save herself somewhere else
nobuoaki's father makes fun of his wife
for accidentally serving four people
when they only have one daughter the
family laughs it off completely
forgetting about nobuoaki's existence
back in school the hurt is too much for
chimi to take she dies six months after
the incident a new girl arrives at
another school in a different town she
is welcomed by chimi who turns out to
still be alive because of the curse the
king's game will continue until she
finds a way to end it herself
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching